[Music]
this is not fake news Michael Keaton is
in talks to return as Bruce Wayne and
Batman in the upcoming flash movie so
let's talk about what we know about this
movie and how the Birdman / Batman might
fit into it right now annika Jeff not
since 1989 s fresh Batman and 1992
certified fresh' Batman Returns has
Michael Keaton played the Caped Crusader
but according to The Hollywood Reporter
the actor is in talks to join the cast
of Warner Brothers is DC film of the
flash which is due out June 3rd 2022 and
the person who wrote the story Boras kid
elaborated on Twitter by saying
sources say Keaton could end up linked
Batman in a mentor capacity kind of like
Sam Jackson's Nick Fury and appear in
multiple movies Batgirl is one of the
possible projects which honestly I have
no words actually I do have words this
makes sense because the latest person to
occupy the Flash's director's chair Andy
machete from the recent it movies
brought on birds-of-prey screenwriter
Christina Hudson who is writing Batgirl
and Bruce Wayne in an expiry type role
could actually kind of films together
nicely sometimes I don't know what to
think about this it's just something I
have to do as far as cast goes other
than Ezra Miller starring is Barry Allen
aka the flash not much else is known gal
the dotes Wonder Woman and ray Fisher
cyborg had been rumored to appear in the
past sure see Clemmons shot scenes as
Barry's love interest
iris West for Justice League but they
were cut also who knows what the
Schneider Cup will bring but now it's
sounding like she won't get a chance to
play the role on screen although nothing
has been confirmed and Billy Crudup who
did appear in Justice League could
possibly return as Barry's father Henry
now that casting would fit especially
well if the movie follows the
reverse-flash storyline where Henry is
falsely convicted of killing his wife
Nora and it just so happens at Matthew
McConaughey has been rumored to be on
Warner Brothers his wish list to play
reverse-flash and to top things off even
further there have also been rumors of
Jessica Chastain playing a female
version of that character which I say
yes and yes McConaughey all day reunited
and elements of that story could
actually work well with the movie
following the long rumored flashpoint
timeline where berry travels back in
time to prevent his mother's murder
causing a time shift and creating a
universe where the Justice League no
longer exists I know this is all very
dark and it's just 9 a.m. where I am but
stick with me here the comics version of
that timeline does include Bruce Wayne
dying instead of his parents with Thomas
Wayne becoming Batman and Martha Wayne
becoming the Joker but machete said back
in January that fans will get quote a
different version of flashpoint than
you're expecting so Keaton could very
well fit into this story and again it's
20/20 expect the unexpected
[Music]
that's enough for me I want to hear from
you guys now what do you want to see in
an upcoming flash movie also how amazing
would it be if Michael Keaton returns as
Batman if he's your Batman and also what
do you guys think about these rumors
about a female Joker let us know all
your thoughts and feelings in the
comments section and for my movie and
trimming news head on over to Rotten
Tomatoes comm also do not forget to join
our fan group on Facebook because
honestly it is a perfect place to fan
cast movies like this one so let me know
who you've got and if you don't want to
miss out on any future episodes of this
show hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always thank
you so much for watching to catch up my
name's as Perez and we hope to see you
guys next time
[Music]
[Music]